I am going to bring on the co-founder
and CEO of locals who also happens to be
my brother-in-law I let him marry my
sister a soft love hello Assaf nice to
see you we'll shake hands uh so I for my
audience
we started they've been with me forever
they heard the adventure of let's start
something let's build something all of
that and I went to you and I was like
Assaf can you build me my own basically
a patreon replacement could we build a
subscription model here can we do it you
built it and then we were like let's
build a company and now it's about two
and a half years later and we merged
with Rumble and Republic uh
pretty sweet yeah you know it's funny
because when you think about it exactly
three years ago September of 2019 oh
yeah this is time the Tweet launched the
Rubin report Community yeah and yes Dave
came to me at the time you were with
patreon if you but at the end of 2018
and he said asafa I need a solution
where I'm going to control my audience
where I will be the boss for my own
business because I cannot rely on those
big Tech and we started to do it but it
was one element that we added to the
mixer that we said that it's not only
that we wanted to build a solution when
you own the data and you own your user
but also a place where your user can
connect to one another and we build it
all under a community and three years
ago we launched the Reuben report
community and I think the power of the
community that we discover is much
greater than anything else yeah because
um the Ruby report Community allowed us
to hire the key employees that we have
in the company yeah the Ruby report we
got I mean literally you're not making
that up I mean we got some of our key
staff members there are people like
they're high up they were up there yes
celebrating that were fans they were
literally fans of the show they reached
out to me and were like how can I get
involved this is my skill set I want to
throw some dollars in whatever it might
be another part of this operation and
that's the point of the community that's
the point of the community we got some
investors to back it up and we built the
product with one thing in mind we said
how can we support free speech and how
can we build a solution where we think
about the Creator first and then you
connected me to some like uh really
interesting creators that had similar
problem yeah and we started to give it
to to more and more creators and we
discover a need in the industry and the
need is that the Creator want to have
full control and connect directly with
the audience but I think what we see
recently and why we are now with rumbel
the entire media landscape is changing
in front of our eyes if in the past you
needed social media to basically have a
distribution Channel today distribution
channels are people like yourself that
already have an audience and we are
betting big time on Creative
Independence and we want to help more
and more creators we saw Steve will do
it that by the way is opening his own
locals Community Steve will do it that
locals.com
that it's going to be available as well
we want to see more people like yourself
more creative successful because you
guys are the future of distribution and
it's interesting also because not only
so we build a good product but our
mission was the same mission that Chris
was building with Rumble the entire time
so when we sat down with him which was
only basically a year and half ago and
we were trying to figure out could we
just work together and basically he was
like forget working together we need to
join forces we need we need to be
together yeah and it happened pretty
quick it happened pretty quick I have to
say that um in the beginning when we
went to people and you know that we had
some investor that missed the
opportunity because when there's a lot
of people eating crow today yeah yes
because uh when they held that we
support Free Speech it was like people
got nervous yeah they thought Free
Speech was some some right-wing thing
that was always the worry and we kept
saying no it isn't they're coming for
everybody this isn't about politics the
lefties can be on here but a certain
amount of people are always afraid yeah
so we got the right investors and I'm
very proud of every investor that joined
uh locals and I think it's a celebration
day for them as well but when we met
Chris it was the first time that we met
the tech CEO the thought in the same way
that he said you know what we can have a
platform where we allow people to share
their opinion regardless if we agree or
disagree with them as long as they obey
the laws of the United States and the
Synergy was perfect we started with the
partnership and I think quickly after we
got the offer to join rambel and for us
I think not only that it was a great
success working together for the past
three years it was the first ride to get
to the moment that we are ringing the
bell together with rumbel but
essentially what we are doing we are
taking Free Speech public and I'm here
in the United States for almost 10 years
yeah I think there is one value new
citizen of the United States by the way
a new citizen thank you very much yes
and there is one value that is unique to
United States by the way and its freedom
and as long as I'm here and as long as I
can like you know help to contribute to
this I'm going to fight for freedom and
I think that's what rambel is doing at
the end of the day you know I know
you've only done a couple interviews but
that was a that was a I'm learning from
the best nice and tight my man you
really tied that thing together
um Can we is there anything we can hint
to the people that might be on the
horizon you know my Local's community
and obviously probably all of them are
watching right now it's a big day uh
they're always asking me what's next
what's next I've been hinting some
things that we're working on and we've
improved our video live streaming
tremendously and a whole bunch of is
there anything we can hint at maybe or
yeah we're going to give a few so first
life sleep is something that we're going
to be uh very bullish and we're going to
keep on improving it more and more the
reason it's because it's the most
authentic form of communication that you
have but what we want to do now and
that's going to come in 2023 we want to
see how we can involve the audience as
well I think that you always say that
your community and you learn a lot from
your community as well you want them to
be more involved in the live stream and
we are going to develop some feature
that will allow them to be more
interactive I call it interactive media
and that's really where we're going to
go the second thing that we released
actually this month was articles because
was what we understand is that creators
not only want to produce videos they
also want to have written content so now
you can also write articles on locals
and you can expand the type of content
that you have and the third thing that
we started in the past few months we
started to sell movies on locals and we
have tremendous success I mean we did
two thousand mules through the Nash and
he absolutely crushed it to say the
least yeah and what Dinesh proved is the
locals Mission what Dinesh proved was
that he can take a movie that he
produced and he can go independent and
do it himself and the results that he
got was mind-blowing and I think now
we're gonna open it up so in the uh in
the near future you guys are going to
hear about it as well it's something
that we call content plus essentially we
believe that every Creator can create
their own on-demand service on their
platform where they can sell movies they
can sell articles if they want they can
sell podcasts and we want to more
Empower you guys to be build your own
business that's something that we're
going to be committed for to keep
empowering our creators to be
independent because we think that they
are the future of media I heard a rumor
that Rumble might go into the email
business perhaps there's some messaging
coming some private messaging for the
people on the local side there's all
kinds of things a lot down the pike
there is a lot of things and a lot of
things that people also need to
understand from rumbel one of the big
reason why we started to even like talk
to Amber to begin with we knew that we
cannot be hosted on big Tech yeah and we
knew that the big challenge with
building our technology if you remember
a lot of people came to us and say where
are you being hosted it's not easy to
build this infrastructure and now I can
tell you from The Insider the rampbell
info infrastructure team are world class
yeah those are world-class people and we
are building more and more servers to
basically support more people and that
they can speak up so we build it on top
of it but now it's going to be time that
we are going to roll out more feature is
what you said more communication more
messaging more involving the community
itself in connecting with the creators
Asaf maybe I'll see you for dinner at
your place tonight I guess you're going
to see it but that was quite a journey
Dave yeah it is only the beginning